Una artista de cuentas, hace un pequeño hoyo
en la esquina superior de una cuenta cúbica,
hacia la esquina opuesta inferior de la cuenta.
Así es que se trata de una cuenta cúbica,
cada arista de la cuenta es de 1/2 centímetro.
¿Cuál es la longitud del hoyo que ella hizo?
Si lo estoy interpretando adecuadamente,
déjame dibujar esa cuenta cúbica,
que voy a dibujar como un gran cubo aquí.
Cubos más bonitos han sido dibujados
en la historia del dibujo de cubos,
pero voy a hacer mi mejor esfuerzo.
Veamos este es mi mejor trabajo
en un cubo a mano libre.
Si este fuera un cubo transparente
podrías ver la parte de atrás así
esta sería la base de este cubo transparente.
Nos dicen que cada arista de esta cuenta cúbica,
le llaman cuenta cúbica,
nos dicen que cada arista de esta cuenta cúbica
mide 1/2 centímetro,
esta de aquí mide 1/2 centímetro
y esta de aquí también mide 1/2 centímetro,
y nos dicen que hizo un pequeño hoyo
en la esquina superior de esa cuenta cúbica,
hacia la esquina opuesta inferior de la cuenta,
de la esquina superior a la esquina opuesta inferior.
Me parece que están hablando de la diagonal mayor que aparece en el cubo,
yendo de la esquina superior derecha trasera,
a la esquina inferior izquierda delantera.
Ahí aparece una de las diagonales mayores del cubo. Déjame dibujarla aquí.
Esta es la distancia que nos preguntan, la longitud del hoyo que ella hizo,
esta es la distancia que necesitamos calcular.
Veamos cómo podemos calcular esto
y este es un problema clásico.
Calcular la longitud de la diagonal mayor de un cubo
o en general de un prisma rectangular,
y el secreto es considerar que ésta
es la hipotenusa de un triángulo.
Aunque dicho triángulo aún no sea obvio para ti
para ver que esta es la hipotenusa de un triángulo,
tenemos que visualizar primero la diagonal que se encuentra en la cara inferior,
esta diagonal
que voy a dibujar aquí.
Esta diagonal que es la diagonal
de la cara inferior de este cubo,
si lo ves de esta manera
aquí tenemos un triángulo rectángulo,
que atraviesa la mitad del cubo,
aquí está el ángulo recto
conocemos este cateto de aquí,
conocemos esta distancia,
si podemos calcular
esta distancia de aquí, esta distancia naranja que corresponde a la diagonal
de la cara inferior del cubo, podremos encontrar la hipotenusa de este triángulo rectángulo,
que es la distancia que nos están preguntando,
la longitud del hoyo que se hizo.
Ahora para calcular esta distancia naranja
tenemos que visualizar la base del cubo.
Hagamos un dibujo.
Si estuviéramos en la parte superior del cubo
viendo hacia abajo,
esto se vería así,
voy a poner colores en los lados,
así va a ser más fácil identificarlos en el dibujo.
Tenemos este lado de aquí que voy a poner en azul,
vamos a dibujarlo aquí, este sería el lado azul.
Este lado de acá vamos a ponerlo en magenta, que se correspondería a este lado de aquí en magenta.
Estos dos lados miden igual, miden 1/2
por eso lo estoy dibujando
aproximadamente del mismo tamaño
y tenemos este lado naranja que es
una de las diagonales de la base del cubo,
lo voy a dibujar con la misma línea punteada.
Ahí lo tenemos, voy a extender un poco más este lado.
Sabemos que este es un ángulo recto, es un cubo,
vamos incluirlo aquí, este es el ángulo recto
este lado mide 1/2 centímetro,
y este lado de aquí mide 1/2 centímetro también.
Para calcular esta longitud que es la diagonal que tenemos aquí, vamos a usar el teorema de Pitágoras.
Sabemos que nuestros catetos miden un 1/2.
Si designamos a la hipotenusa por no sé... digamos "x",
sabemos que el cuadrado de la hipotenusa
es igual a la suma de los cuadrados de estos catetos.
Así es que "x" cuadrada va a ser igual a 1/2 al cuadrado, más 1/2 al cuadrado.
Queremos calcular "x", así es que "x"
va a ser igual a la raíz cuadrada
de 1/2 al cuadrado,
más 1/2 al cuadrado,
1/2 al cuadrado es 1/4 así es que esto es
la raíz cuadrada de 1/4 más 1/4.
Así es que "x"
es igual a la raíz cuadrada
de 1/4 más 1/4 son 2/4
ó lo que es lo mismo, 1/2,  esto también lo podemos escribir como
1 sobre la raíz cuadrada
de 2.
Esto vamos a dejarlo así, por lo pronto.
Así es que esta distancia de aquí es
1 sobre la raíz cuadrada de 2,
que corresponde a esta distancia de aquí que es 1,
sobre la raíz cuadrada de 2.
Dibujemos ahora este triángulo recto cuya hipotenusa es la longitud del hoyo que se hizo en la cuenta.
Aquí tenemos entonces
este de aquí es
el lado largo que tenemos aquí,
luego este lado de aquí en amarillo...
este lado aquí en amarillo mide 1/2,
y este otro lado es el que acabamos de calcular aquí,
es la "x" que calculamos aquí.
Este lado
sería ese que acabamos de calcular aquí.
Tendríamos entonces el ángulo recto del triángulo, este lado que hemos calculado que mide
1 sobre raíz cuadrada de 2.
Ahora para calcular la longitud del hoyo,
podemos aplicar el teorema de Pitágoras nuevamente,
así es que si a este lado le llamamos "h"
"h" de hoyo...
no, mejor vamos a llamarle "l" de longitud,
así que por el teorema de Pitágoras,
tenemos que "l" al cuadrado es igual
a el cuadrado de este lado, 1 sobre raíz de 2 al cuadrado, más el cuadrado de este otro lado que es
1/2 al cuadrado, así es que más 1/2 al cuadrado,
"l" es opuesto al ángulo recto de la hipotenusa
y aplicando el teorema de Pitágoras,
el cuadrado de la hipotenusa es igual a la suma de los cuadrados de los catetos,
así es que esto nos queda
"l" al cuadrado es igual a 1 entre raíz de
2 al cuadrado que es 1 al cuadrado,
que es igual a 1 sobre raíz de 2 al cuadrado, que es 2
más 1/2 al cuadrado,
más 1/2 al cuadrado que es 1/4 y
¿Y esto cuánto nos va a dar?
1/2 más 1/4,
vamos a hacerlo por acá,
común denominador es 4,
así es que esto sería 2/4 más 1/4 que es igual a 3/4,
así es que esto, la suma de estos 3/4, por lo cual,
"l" cuadrada es igual a
3/4
y de donde obtenemos que "l",
sacando raíz cuadrada a ambos lados de la ecuación,
"l" va a ser igual a la raíz de 3/4 o la raíz de 3 sobre 2.
Hemos sacado la raíz de 4 en el denominador,
que es igual a 2,
así es que "l" es igual a la raíz de 3, sobre 2.
Ya lo tenemos, la longitud del hoyo
que se hizo de aquí acá,
hemos calculado que es igual a la raíz de 3 sobre 2 cm,
pues los datos que nos dieron estaban en centímetros.